I know there's a lot of bumpin and
grindin there's a lot of light it's like
me I'm Daniela Dutton I've been teaching
dancing bachata for about 10 years now
and I am here today to show some brand
new people how to dance bachata
but Chopin is my favorite it's a lot
more like intimate and close and it's
meant to be sensual with the person who
you're dancing with gonna drop a dropper
okay so we're gonna start with some
simple stuff we're all gonna go to the
left and you're going to start with your
left foot okay you're gonna go side
together side and you're gonna kind of
raise your hip just a little bit you
want to like straighten out your leg and
we're gonna do the same thing going this
way now we're gonna go right together
and the hip comes up side together I
used to dance as a kid like when I was
really little and then I quit because I
was afraid that it was too girly but as
an adult I realized that being able to
dance is like one of the sexiest things
someone can know how to do so I want
everyone to take their ribs and go to
the left a little bit right like kind of
like you're stretching right you're
gonna go to the right you're gonna go to
the left I'm cramping already Kenny get
out left right left
yeah here we go we're gonna turn to the
left okay so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna go all the way around hit it
was fun it was good I've never been to a
Latin club so I definitely want to go
I'm a little bit scared of all the
grinding that comes later right left
right left in your arms don't let them
hang like this you don't want to look
like this none of this keep your wrists
down elbows kind of out let them hang
like you had two slings on your arms I
think we nailed it so we had the passion
that everybody else made up for with
their technical skills but they didn't
have the spirit of a ChaCha
Michelle can you're falling in love and
so we're gonna be really supportive each
other but everybody's gonna go one pair
at a time all right you guys are ready
for this you're totally ready for this
I love bachata it was really fun I have
realized that this is the one use for
obliques in practical life yeah just
enough sexy it was not as sexy as I
thought oh I think I think you just need
the right environment I think he needs a
drink I need me to bring a job I think
we did a great job I got to know Candace
a whole lot better so that was wonderful
yeah you know I got to dance with a
person named Elvis so that's cool yeah I
would do it again for sure yeah only if
Michelle is my partner though Oh